[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
greetings hello ryan howdy michael hey
folks thanks for tuning in thanks for uh
giving the podcast support i really
appreciate it if you're here for the
first time listen to some other episodes
write a review tell us what you think
you can follow us on the podcast and
keep up to date with what we're doing at
insideypodcast on instagram and facebook
at insideipod on twitter i really
appreciate you choosing this podcast
there's so many other podcasts around
but you know i get deep you know i get
real i keep it real ryan we get deep we
get deep
and we got a great podcast today in just
a second but i just want to share a few
things with you
i am going to be in st louis this coming
weekend to sign autographs tom welling
and i are doing a smallville nights then
i'll be in liverpool the weekend of the
21st
uh i will be
june 10th that weekend i'll be in
illinois metropolis illinois metropolis
illinois signing autographs doing the
smallville nights and then i'll be going
to australia
june 17th through the 27th
perth and sydney get your tickets um a
lot of fun to be had um also
uh want to thank my patrons lovable
patrons i always give them a shout out
at the end all their names top tier
patrons if you want to support the
podcast it means a lot it helps the
podcast substantially go to patreon.com
inside of you
also a big stage at 2 p.m and 6 p.m
um
may 28th 2 p.m and 6 p.m get your
tickets go to stage.com or you can go to
sunspin.com we also have zooms if you
want to get a zoom and i'm on the cameo
that's about all i'll say about that
uh patreon you can join patreon by going
to patreon.com inside of you and support
the podcast uh judd apatow yep
this is one that ryan was star struck
it's not often you meet somebody who
sort of shaped your comedy brain
that's sort of true i mean yeah he
shaped everyone's brain yeah comedy
brain he's uh
what i love about him is he's the kind
of guy that you can direct message into
instagram
and
and say hey i'd love you to do my
podcast he's like yeah absolutely let's
do it i couldn't believe it i mean you
know i get people that are half the
stars he is
one-fourth the stars that don't even
respond
he responded and he came on the podcast
and he was so open and funny and giving
he sent me a whole bunch of cool stuff
to watch to prepare for the interview
like the george carlin special that's
coming out yeah bubble
uh
yeah the bubble i mean he's just uh he's
extraordinary his books uh you're gonna
hear about it all uh without further ado
we should just get into it because it's
a wonderful wonderful time i had with
judd apatow let's get inside of judd
apatow
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience yeah i mean the first thing you
said is like oh you collect [ __ ] i
collect [ __ ] uh
and that made me feel good because i've
had many people like bob odenkirk dak
shepard guys have come in here as i name
drop and they just
uh sort of say what's wrong with you why
do you get autographs why do you collect
things what's what's going on so wrong
that's so bob
it's so so damned
to like [ __ ] on our joy and our
memorabilia
bob and his house without one breaking
bad like fake drug packet yeah that's
what we would have done we would took
the blue
meth right from the set from crop people
and framed it framed it that's where it
should be i have breaking bad
memorabilia in there and i wasn't even
in on the show come on dax could have
had a without a paddle paddle
up on the wall i'm all for that stuff i
remember jim carrey framed some of his
outfits from the movies
in his house he had a movie theater
i still he still does and and so he
would have you know the the ace ventura
outfit
and the cable guy outfit and i thought
that's the coolest thing ever i loved it
i'm all for the worship of all that
stuff when i was a kid obsessed with
autographs yeah so i'm like a kid on
long island i just so want to touch
showbiz i don't know how to do it and as
a little kid the only thing i could
think of was
writing letters and there would be these
little
books you could get
homes of the stars and they'd show like
lucy's house and jimmy stewart's house
and in the back it would have the
address of nbc and abc and i would just
sit there all day long writing
letters to
james garner and hal linden come on you
you did that you you wrote letters to
hundreds of hundreds of them and i got
tons of
weird autographs i have gilda radner's
autograph from back then jackie gleason
they're probably all written by
secretaries i figured out later
and that breaks my heart i doubt it come
on you really think so who knows gilda
seems real
and
and i love that collection and i was
laughing
uh because
there was a like a fire scare in our
neighborhood a few years ago
and like that was one of the first
things i grabbed to put in the car when
we were evacuating was my autograph
collection from sixth grade
hey there's nothing wrong with that no
what do you have first of all your wife
leslie man who i think is [ __ ]
hilarious and
hot can i say that i agree yeah but how
do you i mean does she say no judd we're
not putting that in the house oh she
turned things down oh she knows that uh
that's i'm weird about that stuff and
the funny thing is i know the second i
die it goes in a dumpster there's no one
who'll go like let's go through dead
stuff and i'll hang some of it in my
house to remember dad it's straight in
the burner there's no one who cares
about it i can't get my kids to sit with
me once to go do you want to look look
at it
zero but i have my office
and what do you have in there what are
your like most like the things that you
love the most they're on the wall that
your prized possessions what are those
well i just switched offices my old
office had
what you would expect the posters from
the movies signed and
and photos of everyone we've worked with
things like that then i just moved to
new offices all the walls have nothing
on them because i'm like i guess it's
like a new era
and i should let
the present moment determine it i
shouldn't just
hang all the
freaks and geeks posters like i normally
would do but that's you but the one
thing i did do because i i don't know
what to hang
i was on ebay and somehow i saw that
some guy in canada
spent his whole life taking polaroids
with celebrities and having them sign
the polaroid and in the pictures it
looks like a guy in his early 60s
and they were 140 of them it's literally
like him with the smothers brothers and
then the next one is rudy giuliani and
the next one is some canadian star and
sean cassidy and i bought them and i'm
doing this six foot by six foot frame of
this man who i don't know
and all of all polaroids with
celebrities that's just a conversation
piece so maybe that's the way but that's
cool
yes oh i i think it's the coolest thing
ever but when i tell my family that they
give me a look which shows they don't
think
that's cool really
so mod and iris and and leslie they
don't get autographs they don't care
about that stuff when you go onto a set
by the way do you when you work with
somebody that you were enamored by or
someone you really loved and i don't
know if you feel that way now i don't
know if you get enamored because you've
worked with a lot of great people but
you get you still get a little star
struck do you still like i gotta get
this signed eventually all right or you
don't think like that i certainly do i
guess it's less people because i feel
like as i get older i feel like we're
all trying to do the same thing
so the person that you might have been
in awe of when you were young
when you get older like me you know he's
in the same hell as me trying to write
the new album or
not screw up the new movie right and you
don't feel like they're in another place
you feel like oh that's a an artistic
person trying not to make [ __ ]
so
whoever it is it's mick jagger he's like
how do i make another record people will
pay attention to right but every once in
a while there'll be someone that really
gets you like i was just talking to
somebody about eminem who was in this as
40. oh and that's the kind of person
that i get scared around really one
because
i'm just so in awe
of what he's done
and i'm not in that world nothing
uncommon you feel
i mean i probably do have things in
common but just on the surface my like
child-like anxiety
i feel
uh
intimidated
and and also just whatever the attitude
of of rap
and you know there's a it's so different
than comedy because it's built on
bravado and we're built on like being
proud to be
terrified yes like our insecurities so
it's just a different stance but then he
was righteously funny and realizing and
and was a
huge fan of super bad said he watched it
a zillion times it could literally
recite the movie beginning to end does
that just make you feel awesome oh you
hear that from these guys oh yeah just
the idea of him sitting in his house
watching super bad 30 40 times laughing
you know you also think
how happy is that guy made me
the fact that at some point he's in his
house cracking up at seth
and and jonah and bill hader and emma
and everybody martha in superbad right
you know that's the greatest feeling
ever yeah yeah i can't like the first
thing i thought of when i was going to
talk to you was like and we met doing
stand-up i know you do stand up a lot
you've been stand up your whole life
which we can get into but
you're the first person that's given me
a homework for the interview you gave me
a lot of stuff which was now listen this
was a lot but it was great like i had
the time and no one has seen any of this
which is the the funny part because
i realized that i was very productive
during the pandemic and
i didn't know what that said about me
that during this crisis i just went
straight to work
so i finished my book
sicker in the head which is another book
of interviews with comedy people right
and some you know jeff tweedies in it
too and gayle king but it's mainly like
sasha baron cohen and nathan fielder and
and everybody yeah and so i i was like
everyone's home
they have to say yes timing they can't
say no i know they're home and i know
they're going on
and they're all vulnerable and in a
place where they're thinking about
things i'm sure you found that during uh
your podcast that people are just
much more reflective than they were sure
and then i had been working on this
george carlin documentary i started it
right before the pandemic
awesome let me tell you i i didn't
really i hate i'm embarrassed to say but
i really it's not that i wasn't a big
george carlin fan i just wasn't educated
on him and this boy is this an education
of george carlin the influence he had
who he was the hardships he went through
when he hit rock bottom and like other
comedians were sort of making fun of him
at a certain time you know when he was
doing blow and his wife was an alcoholic
and his daughter stuck in the middle all
of this [ __ ] i was like
this is intense as hell and i really
learned a lot i love this documentary
when does it come out uh it's going to
come out mid to late may
and i'm really proud of it in the
beginning i thought i don't know how we
could do something as good as the gary
shandling documentary because gary was
so open about his feelings he really
expressed himself right in every
situation he just he was just cut in a
vein everywhere that's what he was
looking for he was looking for the
answers right yeah and he wanted to tell
you what he was feeling and he wanted to
go deep and he wanted to talk about
going deep so when you would look up
interviews that he did with people like
kevin smith or mark maron
it was all there i mean there was a
great line gary had in one of the
interviews i think it was with mark
maron
it might have been kevin smith he said
life is short
but not short enough
and so there was all this stuff and i
thought well george carlin never told us
anything about himself was it just the
period was the sense of like just the
time period that he sort of grew up in
probably i mean it was an era where we
didn't know that much about alan king's
life right and people from that era and
his act none of it was personal
zero he didn't tell you about his wife
and his daughter and
he
he it was all in his mind and his
observations of people and life but it
wasn't an observation of his behavior
right and then when he did interviews he
he rarely went deep about any of it but
then we found
that he was working on his autobiography
with tony hendra uh who played the
manager in spinal tap who was a
writer and he passed away i believe this
year
and
he
talked to tony for this book for 23
hours and we found these tapes
and you listen so when you make a
documentary how much harder is it to
make a documentary than actually making
a film because you have a script you
follow the script you you know
but with a documentary it's sort of like
the research that goes into it to find
all these things and then piece them
together and make it somewhat linear
how long do you have a team of people
helping you out with this
oh yeah i mean it's it's a lot of work
to
to just listen to his 14 hbo specials
you listen to every special i mean
i can't say i listen to every second of
every special i usually use my team to
go let's prioritize
there's a lot of stuff that isn't as
good as the best stuff right and so we
don't have to you know get
super deep on the things that weren't
working but it becomes clear that if
there's 14 hours of stuff
maybe there's four incredible hours that
we have to really pay attention to and
our editor joe beshinkowski who did the
shandling dock and uh kurt cobain dock
and he did belushi
he's incredible he remembers everything
he literally remembers everything if he
watches a special it's just
seems to be all in his mind and he's a
real artist and a big part of our
process and my partner michael bonfiglio
who uh
who i also did
a 30 for 30 about dwight good and
endearing strawberry i
that was [ __ ] phenomenal and i know
you're a big met fan yes you're from
flushing well i was born in flash
flushing i was born in long island
and you know i know what it's like to
feel like a loser because i'm a rangers
fan i'm a mets fan i'm a knicks fan i'm
a giants fan giants have had some
success give me the lineup 86 lineup in
the world series for the match can you
do it
it's so funny because i just watched
that uh
the documentary about the mets
uh
awesome six parter or some [ __ ] yeah it
was fantastic uh so let's see i'll let's
see who i can remember all right who was
this wally backman lenny dykstra
these are right dijkstra let it off then
i mean i i don't know if i could say it
all in order kevin mitchell oh yes uh
keith hernandez nice
let's see how how how deep i can go i
have a terrible memory that's the other
thing really
i have a pretty bad
memory like i just thought oh my god
you're gonna you're gonna forget
ron darling oh yes jessie orosco yes uh
you know what i did i was i was watching
that documentary
and i went online
and i don't know if it was connected to
the documentary as like like an extra
on espn it might have been that they had
one of the games from the world series
and i watched a bunch of
the game and it was bob costas
doing the game it was interesting how
slow it was and how
baseball and television
they they hadn't decided to try to find
ways to amp it up and there's a
commercial on the screen during the game
and music and energy and it was really
fun and relaxing it was just so relaxing
listen to the
commentators and it was a completely
different vibe i just remember joe
garagiola yeah and vince scolie and
they're announcing a game and just like
it's so chill it's like you know and the
big question will be whatever happened
to oil can boyd high drive in a right
field henderson goes back and it's gone
and if you're a young daryl strawberry i
mean i just remember these moments like
that sure i mean so you're a mets fan i
love that
i love doc and daryl that was fantastic
did you get to hang out with him a lot
mike
my partner you know did all the
interviews
my
you know my role i feel in a lot of
these documentaries is to really
locate the heart of it
you know i i look at it as a storyteller
for instance in that documentary we
we solely realized that doc was still
struggling
and it was very difficult to
figure out the edit because we thought
we were making a documentary about two
people
who had triumphed over their addictions
and he was still dealing with the
addiction slowly we were like i think
that's not what this is and then i
wasn't sure what the ethics were
of discussing that in any way
and
i didn't want to make a documentary
outing someone that was trying to be
secret about the fact that they still
especially when they think your motive
is to be talking about how they
overcame right this [ __ ] and now it's
like you that that's very that's a tough
thing yeah i'm not trying to
make them look bad right but at the same
time as soon as we start it we have to
be honest about what we're seeing
and i think we made some artful choices
to indicate what was happening right let
the audience kind of
see what's going on as opposed to
stuffing it down their throat and just
be careful about what we were saying
when so you could do the math
to see
that this is a struggle that lasts your
entire life
and and you know maybe daryl hasn't
fallen off the wagon but he owns rehabs
so in order to stay sober he has to
literally own rehabs
that's how often he has to reinforce
these messages and and doc obviously
he's fallen on and off the wagon he got
arrested after the movie was made
and struggles and you know i certainly
pray that he
can overcome all of that yeah
but it was it was interesting to try to
look at these two men
who had a similar experience they they
were very very young and the city
looked to them
to
change everything yeah and then they did
but they were too young to handle new
york city and cocaine and partying in
the 80s which was the 80s at its worst
and it ate them up and they were i think
they were very brave to
you know to talk about it and there's
some interesting material in the the
new mets documentary which everyone
should say i wish you would make a movie
about the 86 mets
about those playing those flights those
there's no books about them i mean i
know but wouldn't that be a fascinating
movie yeah well i think it's all even
darker than we think it got it's almost
like unacceptable right now to even
bring some of the [ __ ] i think so i
think
and like a lot of businesses
there are things happening
that are even beyond right that when you
dig deeper
uh there's there's behavior
you know that is uh
you know
well i i i i don't want to use the word
criminal but but you know there's a lot
of bad things happening yes you know
that
it's not even about today you know it's
just how people treated each other how
they treated women
right and different time period not to
say it was right and it wasn't but it
was a different
well different time period in the sense
that i don't think society had said
no [ __ ] way
we're not doing any of this right and so
something about the culture was a party
studio 54. society hadn't put their foot
down no and i think that you know
certainly the world of athletes
uh is not a world that is about
respecting women and their boundaries
and understanding consent and things
like that right it is a world of people
partying hard getting each other wasted
and everything that flows from that
right you know which is generally not
good
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon don't go anywhere because if you
haven't had magic spoon you're truly
missing out i love this cereal when i
was a kid i loved cereal but then i got
older and it was all these sugars and
all these horrible things that they put
in these cereals and then magic spoon
happen ryan we've we've had some ryan
spoon here on the show some ryan ryan
spoon we've had some magic spoon right
on both yeah we've had both
and uh we do love it and uh since i
started incorporating magic spoon in my
daily morning routine um
i've noticed fewer cravings
throughout the day
because that's my fix man
cereal is my fix
and look let me tell you about magic
spoon not only is it delicious and comes
in different flavors zero grams of sugar
13 to 4 grams 13 to 14 grams of protein
only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
only 140 calories a serving
keto-friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free and low-carb what else you got
ryan and you can build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter cookies and cream maple
waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the newly
reformulated honey nut flavor that will
now be added to magic spoon's permanent
collection they just keep getting new
flavors for this magic spoon i've had
friends by the way call me an email dude
seriously man between us is magic spoon
good yeah and i'm like yeah i don't know
what else to tell you it's delicious and
then they text me back and they go yeah
it's really good thanks thanks for that
uh i love magic spoon and it's easy to
get magic spoon you just go to
magicspoon.com
to grab a custom bundle of cereal and be
sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked i
don't know how you don't try out magic
spoon try it out for me if you like the
podcast you believe what i'm saying i
think you're gonna really dig it try
magic spoon remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode of inside of you
inside of you is brought to you by
farady uh
this is another product that if you look
in my closet we can go up there after so
you sho so you see ryan that i am not
lying i have at least six shirts and a
few skeletons and a few skeletons in the
closet yeah but the ferrite shirts are
so you can't believe how comfortable
they are they almost feel like stretchy
they're so soft they're light you could
wear them anywhere and i know that you
know the the summer's coming and people
are like you know what do i wear
ferritis something that you could wear
to to look good just to look good at any
time it's not too fancy but it could
look nice enough to be fancy it looks
laid back at the same time it's just a
cool cool product faraday is a
family-run brand making high quality
timeless clothing with modern design and
functionality it's that kind of
effortless style you want every time you
go digging into your closet that set
that shirt that dress that feels like
you've had them for years maybe it's in
a gorgeous print and it looks like it
might be vintage but it fits so well
that it feels like it was just made
yesterday just for you
well that's verity yeah and people it's
funny because i always say hey feel this
shirt matt no no i don't want to feel
your shirt i go no no no
feel my shirt and then they feel it my
friend denise felt my shirt she was like
wow i'm like yeah
faraday
faraday's pretty incredible faraday's so
confident the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality they'll replace or fix your
clothes forever who does that no matter
what
they will replace your clothes
forever they will fix or replace your
clothes forever talk about making it
easier to get dressed and right now
faraday is giving all my listeners
inside of you listeners twenty percent
off that's twenty percent off
head to
faritybrand.com and use code inside of
you at checkout to snag twenty percent
off all your new spring staples that's
code inside of you at faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com for twenty percent off
faraday brand dot com for twenty percent
off
how do you how do you do it i mean
you you don't stop working it's like
when i was getting all this stuff i was
like how does he have he's got two kids
he's married he's got this movie the
bubble coming out he's got a documentary
come out he wrote a new book he's got
all this [ __ ] i'm like
you're like
how do you do it how do you balance this
without getting divorced and how do you
are you a workaholic would you honestly
say you have to constantly be working or
you'll be miserable
it's hard to know because i just went
away uh with leslie for nine days to
hawaii and i always felt pretty good in
the shutdown you didn't work
not much i mean i had to make some calls
but i wasn't you know pounding it there
i i i shut it down and
sometimes just you know a summer where
we're mainly in shut down and i
certainly can handle it but i think
that's the thing i'm always trying to
decide you know
am i working for a healthy reason
am i just trying to keep myself busy and
distracted am i passionate about what
i'm doing
you know what what is the actual
motivation for work right you know i've
done a bunch of things
do i need to do another one here like
this
right or am i just kind of on a
treadmill
where things come up and you're busy and
you haven't really thought through if
you want to give your time to it
does leslie make you aware sometimes of
it like hum hello
oh absolutely i think that you know the
rhythm of her career is also different
than the rhythm of a producer's
career in a writer's career so actors
have to be ready when called into action
right right and so and there's periods
between it which can be long
and then you go and you're 100 committed
to
making that movie and creating that
character and then you go home and you
rest and you wait and you can you know
take a hunk of time to recharge where
for me
everything is
you know a long multi-year process so
we're working on billy eichner's
movie which comes out in the fall
you know we've been working on that
movie for five years when you say
working on for five years is it sort of
intermittent like you know
notes every like every couple months
like oh we got to go back to that
because i know you probably have a lot
of plates spinning so is it one of these
things that every couple of months you
have to kind of answer these it's like
when is it how long before it comes into
fruition
well you know it's meetings and
discussions of the outline for a long
time and then suddenly billy and nick
stoller who wrote it with him and
directed
you know do a pass so you're waiting
like for me it's different than them
they're working
a lot of that time and i'm waiting
to be fresh eyes and give a good read
and have discussions about what's
working and then it becomes all right
well how are we gonna
make this how much money do we need to
make this how long would it take who
should be in it
how would you market it
yeah and then that's
years of those
conversations and that's true you might
have eight of these going at the same
time right and you don't know if they're
going to go and sometimes you work on it
for half a decade and then
suddenly everyone says we don't want to
make it
and you how often does that happen
more than you think i mean it happens
you know for sure how personal do you
take that depends on the project
sometimes
you know it's very personal because
you're really ready to go and maybe the
last second the whole thing crumbles
and it's like a runner stumbling and
what causes that usually for something
sometimes last minute casting dr drops
out and then you can't
crack
the perfect chemistry casting again
because i'm all about that if i if if
that doesn't feel right i always say
there's no reason to go i'll never push
something forward
if i don't think all that is a home run
right and sometimes people just say oh
people don't want a movie like that
anymore oh that movie's too weird
yeah we just put out a weird movie and
uh we don't think people like weird
movies and suddenly you're like wait i
got four of these
oh [ __ ] that are kind of eccentric and
they're not
you know
a generic type of movie
right but it it definitely does happen
you have to spin the plates because i
remember early in my career i spent like
three or four years on one script
because i thought that's what you do
what script was that i wrote a script
with owen wilson
and it was right after bottle rocket
which i love and uh the cables guy love
i love bottles rockwell just genius and
we we wrote this script about
a man who got in a drunk driving
accident but wasn't an alcoholic and his
sponsor
at a.a where he was forced to go by the
courts
was riptorn
and it was ripped torn convincing him
that he was an alcoholic even though he
wasn't
and the strange friendship
between them
and i worked on it for years and just
right when i was ready to go
it was no we don't want to do it
and it never happened and it ever
happened how often do they never come
back or how often do they
come back like projects that you are
they say no we're not doing this how off
because you hear these things like
kickball
dodgeball
dodge ball
and it took 12 years and the studio
didn't want to do it and they didn't
want to do it and finally after 12 years
that seems like it rarely rarely happens
when something's turned down it hangs in
there and comes back i mean we've had
that a fair amount of time super bad
took forever
i mean super red was floating around
when we were doing
freaks and geeks wow and we made it in
2006
or around six or seven uh and they had
been working on it since they were like
13 years old i mean this was their seth
and evans dream was was this movie and
everyone said no forever
and then
other movies started succeeding
like talladega nights
and things that i was working on
and then people said what what else do
you have and so we had a trunk of
rejected projects
the other one was pineapple express
which
was only written because we couldn't
believe anyone there was no one to make
super bad and so we were like what's
more commercial than superbad oh we
could do like a stoner action movie like
what if jerry bruckheimer made a stoner
movie perfect her action movie and then
we sent that around and everyone was
like
now we don't like that either
and then
when superbad did well they were like
okay we'll do pineapple
after that so once you've proven
yourself or once you see that there's
success in this they go oh we believe in
this filmmaker we believe in this team
we'll give them this other one yeah we
get
seth and evan's
sense of humor and their style and we
see what what seth is doing on screen
and
suddenly it gets a little bit
easier yeah and
but we've had things get delayed like
you don't mess with the zohan
so
adam says to me adam sandler do you want
to write this movie with robert smeigle
about a hairdresser
a mossad agent in israel who wants to
move america to america and retire
and be a hairdresser
and
so i worked on that with robert smickel
who's the best comedy writer in the
world
so
we had a script we really liked in
like 2000
around that time
and then
911
happens
and we were like oh
i guess you can't do that
now
like everything about what we're
satirizing is much more
heated right
i think we
put it in a trunk before 9 11
when there was the intifada
a year or two before that
and then
every once while
we would take a run at could you rewrite
it i thought after 9 11 there was a way
to do the movie about a cell a terrorist
cell and i i was saying you know can't
we do it about
like rob schneider is in a terrorist
cell
and he slowly falls in love with america
and then in the end he doesn't want to
do it and that he teams up with adam and
then that didn't happen right and and
probably shouldn't have
uh
and then one day sandler just called me
and just said
we're gonna do you don't mess with the
zohan and that was
ten years later 10 years later and
smigiel rewrote it and got it ready to
go and
it was a big
hit and hit a window where people
were willing to laugh about
conflict because it really was a satire
of the ridiculousness of people fighting
and not understanding each other not
caring about each other i mean it's a
very silly
movie but that was the idea that you
could do a really goofy movie that in
his heart was about
that
it's ridiculous that this that it's just
an endless cycle of of violence we
obviously weren't getting into any real
issues right of the middle east but
somehow
it happened at a time when
it had quieted down enough where people
really enjoyed the movie yeah do you
miss
any project from yesteryear like over
the years all these projects you have is
there one that you're just like you got
to make that some day got to make that
someday and and also are there most of
those projects that you're like yeah i
could see why i think it made i don't
i'm never going back there
i'm trying to think what's you know
sitting around there's not too many
sitting around
i wrote a movie for will ferrell and
jack black
like 20 years ago
that was called demon streets and it was
about two motorcycle cops
and
it was all based on the the like the
tupac and biggie murders
like them caught up in the middle of a
similar situation
and
that didn't go and that's that's one
that i think oh at the end still
kind of like i want to see will and jack
on motorcycles
yeah who doesn't
that would be fantastic um what were you
like growing up
where i know that you know you were 12
years old
when your parents split right uh yeah
like 14 14. was that difficult for you
i was like the defining
you know trauma
you know for me
because
you know when you're a little kid
and and
the only thing you have in life is is
these two people getting along
and you listen to them and you're
looking for wisdom from them but when
they're at full war with each other and
back then
parents didn't go
hey we're getting divorced but let's go
to therapy to figure out the best ways
to not make it hard on the kids they
just you know
[ __ ] off they just battled yeah in front
of you
like in front of you oh yeah i know they
know these things i mean this was a time
when
they didn't even think
let's not do this in front of the kids i
don't think i ever heard the phrase
let's not do this in front of the kids
that's funny because my parents my dad
said i wanted you guys to get through
high school and college before we i did
it for you i'm like well why the [ __ ]
did i wish you wouldn't have you guys
were [ __ ] horrible yeah so they got
divorced after you left yeah i was 26 27
and i was like
around there and i was like god i wish
you would have got divorced way earlier
than that it was terrible
yeah i think
someone said once it's better to uh
to to be f
from a broken home
than to grow up in a broken home
something like that that's pretty good
it makes absolute sense but
so that that i think mentally was was
hard for me because i felt like
they're they're making a lot of mistakes
and now i don't know what i should
believe of what they tell me to do with
my life
because i see they're not making good
decisions and how they're treating each
other
yeah and that's the thing
that threw me and also
they
they fought
for
a decade it wasn't a rough three months
it just went fully into my
adulthood it wasn't a wound that
resolved itself and so it just kept
going and going and through college and
going and going and
that certainly motivated me to want to
get my [ __ ] together and know how to
make a living and know how to take care
of myself
yeah because i felt like oh i need to be
on my [ __ ] did it also help you
focus on god i have to go out with
healthy women
i have to
i want to be in something healthy or did
it sort of deter you away from dating
for a while or just hooking up with
girls maybe at a certain age and just
enjoying yourself and going i'm not
getting married after what i've seen
i didn't really think about it in those
terms i just thought
there's a better way to do it than that
yeah and i i i understand more about it
now
you know when i got older and i could
talk to my parents about and i talked to
my mom a little bit about it before she
passed and
it was easier for me to understand them
and now that i'm older than they were
when that was happening
i have more of a sense of what went
wrong and also what went wrong and how
they were taught to relate to
to their spouses in the marriage and
that they didn't learn from their
parents how to communicate and how it
was a domino effect yeah i mean you know
people who were just a generation fresh
to the united states
they they didn't know the psychology of
communication and how to talk to each
other and how to address difficult
things with each other so it would just
erupt because there's no language
for how to
listen i i mean it's like we know what
deep listening is and and
you know
my whole world is self-help books
but they really you read a lot of
self-help books oh constantly but when i
was a kid i remember my dad got
this book called your erogenous zones
by
like wayne dyer
and
it was a first self-help book ever in
the house
and then they got divorced
oh no i remember my dad said to me once
that he
went to therapy with my mom
and the therapist was just hard on my
mom
just whatever he went to a therapist and
in that session the one time they went
he was hard on my mom and my mom was
like
we're not doing that again
and sometimes it's as simple as that
right you get the shitty therapists oh
yeah who doesn't know how to manage the
the moment and it shuts off the idea of
self-exploration and later in life i
pushed my mom to go to a therapist she
was being you know really
you know manic and neurotic and hard to
deal with and i finally got her to go
and then she came back and i said how
was it and she said he told me i was
right about everything
that's what i wanted the best therapist
ever
yeah
uh you your mom's working in a in a
comedy store and you started doing
comedy
what is she doing there first of all
well what happened was
my mom
moved out
and so we were
in sassett and and she moved to
southampton
and
they owned a restaurant together
and one of the bartenders was this guy
rick messina i know rick messina does he
still have the wiffle ball stadium in
the back of his house he built a wiffle
ball stadium in his backyard strawberry
fields exactly yeah and so he was the
bartender at the restaurant they owned
and so when she was divorced
she didn't have any money so she started
waiting tables and selling ads that
radio for radio stations
and this is an upper middle class
woman who just wanted to play tennis and
raise her kids all day and now she's
you know blue collar in the workforce
right and he
would run a comedy club out of this
hotel the southampton inn in the summers
and
he hired her to be the hostess
and so looking back and i've said this
before
i always thought what did he pay her
what do you pay someone in 1984 83 to
seat people
at a comedy club
not a lot
i mean
minimum wage then was 3 35 i remember so
what could she have made and then i
thought well on some level i would
assume she just did it for me
because she would want me to see it
really because i was such a comedy freak
and she never indicated that ever
and and on some level it was a
humiliation to her to work
for her bartender
you know she was like someone that her
grand her father was a big record
producer who produced janice joplin and
i think she came from a lot of money
and now she's seating people at a comedy
club all rich people all the people that
she would be embarrassed to have that
job in front of because my mom is very
materialistic
and very aware of that stuff
and i love that she had those kind of
jobs i just thought it was cool like oh
my mom's a waitress at this diner that's
amazing yeah but to her it was terrible
and
i think on some levels she must have
thought
or maybe
psychically
felt
there's a reason to do this because it's
where i met all the comedians and how i
started interviewing comedians rick gave
me a job as a dishwasher at eastside
comedy club in huntington and everything
flew
came out of
my mom taking that job as a hostess
at this college if she didn't take a job
as a hostess in a comedy store
do you think your career would have been
completely different
a thousand percent because i
you know i started working as a
dishwasher then a busboy and i would
watch the comedians i used to watch
eddie murphy and rosie o'donnell in like
1983-84
and
that's how i made some connections that
paid off later in life and it was
where i first did stand-up in high
school was at eastside comedy club
jackie martling used to always come into
there and it was like bob nelson and rob
bartlett and all the long island legends
and
that gave me the courage to interview
comedians because i had met them so i
thought oh i would love to interview
them so i interviewed them for my high
school radio station and that's when i
was able to say how do you do it how do
you get on stage how do you write jokes
what's this going to take because really
that's why i interviewed people
initially to figure things out just to
figure things out and to to make them
real because you know you see hal linden
on tv he's like a magical
figure yeah right and then when you get
in the room with people you think oh
this is possible you're a person oh
jerry seinfeld in 8384. he's from long
island oh you're kind of like me
so it's not crazy that i would dream
that i could do this do you remember the
first time you went on stage that very
first time well my dad was great he used
to drive me to these clubs chuckles
in mineola shackles and and governors in
levittown which is a great club which is
still there levitt town wow and he would
drive me and drop me off and pick me up
a few hours later
and they were both very supportive my
mom and dad
although they had issues with each other
both
always said you could do it
and
believed 100 and that was the main
reason why i think i had so they always
believe confidence
they not for a second thought
that there was a chance i would fail
were they loving were they like i love
you whatever you yeah i'll be happy they
were like that yes 100
and so that was never a question
like there was no shame of this is a
dumb profession right they knew i loved
it and they were excited for me to try
to jump into it
and so i would go to all those clubs as
an open micro
in high school and that that's how i did
you really enjoy it did were you
enjoying it or were you nervous nervous
wrecked to begin with oh you started to
the diarrhea the diet dude what is that
i when i started doing i just i i would
have died i wouldn't understand it it
would be like explosive diarrhea every
time i before i would go up yeah i would
just fall apart
so exhausted feel like [ __ ] and i was so
terrible at it were you i mean i was so
bad when i started when i think about
things i did on stage
i'm like your worst fringe freak in an
open mic night who's terrible
but i just kept doing it and i i learned
that
it would take a while to figure it out
that's what comedians told me that it
takes a while to figure out who you are
so in my head every time i bombed i
thought oh i'm on the path
it's good that i'm bombing
because i am learning how to do this by
bombing and i had a pretty healthy
patience
about just getting through this early so
you were comfortable at some point just
bombing you were used to it i wasn't
comfortable i hated it
but i was willing to do it right and i
thought well i'm 17 years old if it
takes me eight years to be a worldwide
megastar so be it i i'm 25. so i had
this psychotic
feeling like it'll work out like it
actually didn't work out but i mean i
did get good enough to
to start traveling and right being a
normal comedian you go to usc we're fast
forwarding this the whole thing is not
going to be that linear but i don't care
um but you go to usc you you have a
you're part of a writing program and you
drop out after two years what was the
reason why you dropped out
we didn't have enough money to pay
tuition that's what it was the main
thing which is no one had the money
to pay for it yeah
but it's funny because you look back and
you go
it is an expensive school how much was
it
the tuition was six grand
a semester in 1985-86
and
it literally wasn't possible for me to
get six grand
there was just no way to get it and i
got exhausted trying to
figure that out and push everybody
for the money
and everyone was having real serious
financial problems at that time right
and so i was a little bit half-assed at
school because i thought
i'm not going to finish this program and
you liked it i liked it at the beginning
and then i think i started getting
bummed out
that it was clear that i i couldn't do
it i couldn't afford the film and the
camera rentals and it it just wasn't
gonna work and then i think i
lost some interest in it and i was
getting more interested in stand up
so when i left my family wasn't like oh
man no let's we got to figure out how to
get that money they were like great what
are you going to do now yeah yeah and
and i had been doing some stand-up at
college and booking shows at
usc when i was there but i did learn how
to write i had one class with sid field
the guy who wrote you know the
screenwriting book that everybody reads
and later when i had friends who
started getting opportunities i realized
oh i think i know how to write
screenplays
it's like that scene in taxi where out
of the blue reverend jim starts playing
the piano and he plays the most amazing
classical piece and then he stops and he
goes
i guess i
took lessons
that's how i felt when like suddenly
friends needed writers
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy i
can't tell you how many emails or texts
or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them
and i really love that i love uh
talking about something that works that
helps people that is a sponsor on the
podcast where we talk about mental
health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping it's still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face
you don't have to you could also text
you could have it you could do whatever
you want it's so much more affordable
than in-person therapy
trust me on that one
going in
in-person therapy is is so expensive
it's i i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far uh you could be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress i believe it really
can truly this podcast is sponsored by
better help and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash
inside give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
wow
what was it like i mean you've said it
before like you were roommates with
sandler but everybody wants to know at
least a story what was he like living
with at that young age was he like
john do the [ __ ] dishes
no
it wasn't like that adam adam always had
a rental car
and he never ever cleaned it he would
just return it when it was filled almost
to the roof with fast food
like garbage
that was like a really weird thing that
he did he just he wouldn't wash it and
he would trash it return it get a fresh
one
for years he he did that i mean
at that time and i think it's a lot
different than now
comedy was much smaller there was no
internet
and
you felt like the whole comedy business
was about 100 people
and
there were certain people you would meet
and you would think i think that
person's going to be a gigantic star
even when they weren't near it at all
you felt the bubbling up of certain
people like adam you felt jim carrey
living with him you like this there's
something about this guy everyone around
adam was like adam's adam's the next
eddie murphy
you just knew it even when he was
bombing it wasn't like he was killing on
stage and you thought that as a result
of the success
of his performances right we found him
hilarious the crowds was hit and miss
but there was a certain charisma which
is the charisma
which led to everything that happened
that you felt when he was in his early
twenties
if anything hotter because he had so
much energy as a friend
to make you laugh because he wasn't
making movies so all that energy that
he's put into his career in the early
days was just used on you at dinner
because he was so funny and he didn't
have an outlet what would he say
he just was
at that time a very
you know gregarious
loud hilarious
person right he loved to make everybody
in our group laugh
and i think when you become super famous
that quiets down a bit because in a way
the world is paying attention to you
right that when no one knows who you are
no one's paying attention to you
it's more fun to make a spectacle out of
yourself it's a freedom too isn't that
yeah and and you still have the
knucklehead energy that we all had of
college right and you've just brought it
into the into the real world so he was
just making us laugh as friends
a ton
and then
you know he would do
you know phony phone calls
all the time because i i really felt
like it was
he didn't know what to do with this
energy and he would just you know call
jerry's deli and complain about
a turkey sandwich that made him sick and
really put them through it for like 15
minutes of negotiations about can he
have a free sandwich
and
what kind of sandwich can the free one
be does it have to be the same sandwich
as the one that made me sick i had the
turkey but maybe i'll have roast beef
this time
and
i was aware that this was something
special i started recording it because
as a comedy fan i'm like i'm aware that
no one's this funny
that i'm not just like with some guy
that this is world class funny this is
the people that i love like michael
keaton and
seinfeld this is another
another level and i believe it's gonna
turn into something and then it then the
weird thing is you know one day he says
hey i just got saturday night live and
then he's gone
wow
that's incredible you know i look at all
this [ __ ] not [ __ ] sorry but you
produced all this i call it [ __ ] you do
yeah sure good for you it's your [ __ ]
man you produced cable guy anchor
mentality at night super bad pineapple
express for getting sarah marshall get
him to the greek bridesmaids the big
city and first of all i think you know
you're 54 years old you're five years
older than me and i feel like a complete
[ __ ] failure i love all the [ __ ]
you've done but i look 20 years older
than you no you don't if you shave you
have gray hair that's it that's the only
[ __ ] difference but one thing you
know people talk about is freaks and
geeks and just briefly you know i've
read inter interviews where you talk
about
i knew it was gonna get canceled i knew
every week was that is that true did you
really feel like from the get-go oh yeah
this is gonna get canceled and why what
was the studio's complaints why did you
feel that this wasn't gonna make it
well we made it at a time when there was
no head of nbc
so
the head of programming left and
suddenly there was a more business
oriented guy
who was above him who got to make all
the decisions and because he wasn't some
programming guy who felt the need to
ruin your process
he just loved the script and we said hey
we want these people in it and he went
great
usually as you know the the network
will
screw with your casting choices because
it's the only place that they really can
mess with your show so when you go i'd
like this person to be the lead they're
like bring me four choices
which is the dumbest part of all of
television is this moment where you
debate the network so if you create a
show
and you say i want this person as the
lead
if you lose that fight you've already
ruined your show your show is done you
might as well not shoot it
it's it's all about that
and so we've had good and bad
experiences with that but in this
experience he just green lit everything
we shoot the pilot
uh jake kazdan came in to direct it we
had bill pope as the cinematographer who
did like the matrix it's one of the
greats of all time and paul feig was
just so tuned into what he wanted to do
with that type of show
and
then they hired a head
of programming
and very quickly someone just said he
doesn't like it
just didn't get it he doesn't get it
they said he went to private school he
he's not feeling it and so
from the very beginning we knew we were
in trouble and
you know you can see it in the time slot
in the marketing and
the fact that we would be on for a week
and off for two weeks and back for two
weeks and off for three weeks
so there was no rhythm to create a
relationship with the audience
and we felt like our days were numbered
and then he took me out to lunch and he
said can your characters have more
victories
because it was a melancholy show about
getting your ass kicked and and the
solace you take from your family and
your friends when you're really having a
hard time
and you say no that's not what this
show's about
yet i had to and i was young enough to
not know
that
that it's bad to be honest
i didn't really know how to work those
relationships yeah yeah and so the thing
that i did to give him a victory was
there was an episode where bill is in
gym class
and there's a high pop that comes up to
him
and he catches it and he goes crazy
celebrating
and then he doesn't realize that it's
not the final out and everyone is
scoring and tagging up
that was as close as a victory right
and
so
it did turbocharge the show because
you know when you think you might get
canceled at any second
you know you use all your good ideas
nothing saved for season two and three
right and so it became a bit compressed
yeah and you shot the finale
we shot the finale like three episodes
before the end of the season which is
crazy we didn't want it to end abruptly
on nothing unsettled right and so
i remember paul and i were in las vegas
that's hilarious i flew to vegas
to see rodney dangerfield with adam
and by the way that's my favorite
comedian of all time yeah he so he yeah
he's the one that we we you know we
loved i had seen him as a kid and we got
to hang out with him it was a magic
night but i bumped into feig who
happened to also be in vegas and we were
just talking about it and
i was like man let's just do the final
episode
he hadn't directed i felt
i felt bad but he was the best writer on
the show it was such a vision for him i
didn't think that he could
keep up with the writing if he was
directing
and so i i hadn't let him direct
because i just felt that that was so
important right and so i said just write
and direct the last episode
and then we'll shoot it in the middle of
the season so if we get canceled we'll
have a finale
and in our conversations in vegas we
were like what happened to lindsay and
we thought i think she'd become a
deadhead like that seems to be the
middle between the burnouts
and the athletes would be the deadhead
and then paul wrote and directed the
most incredible finale it's it's really
remarkable then i felt guilty that he
hadn't directed more episodes but i
think the reason why the whole show is
good is because
uh he hadn't do you do you see that not
now but
retrospectively when you well when you
were on set you get cancelled did how
did you deal with that failure was it
did it was it overwhelmed because you
don't deal it seems like you don't deal
with a lot of failure in your life maybe
i'm wrong
i i didn't handle any of that well
because
i really had this gut feeling that magic
was happening while we were shooting it
it didn't matter if anyone was watching
it
i just thought
i think this is great and the idea that
someone would just go stop doing it it
felt like if you were
a guitar player and someone walked up to
you and said i'm taking away your guitar
and you're never getting another one for
the rest of your life
that's what it felt like jesus and i had
to sense this is
this doesn't happen this combination of
writers and actors and directors and
crew
this is special so the idea that someone
would end it
you know led to me just internalizing
all this rage and
and you know i got a herniated disc and
i was on vicodins and
in the editing room ranting and
and
it was just a terrible time i remember i
was like being really not nice to the
editor
he everything but i'm also on vicodin of
course right and i've been there uh i'm
not being nice in because he just keeps
like something very simple he just keeps
doing wrong over and over and over again
and i'm just like man what is wrong with
you what is wrong with you or just
something like that and he's like
my friend died yesterday
oh man and i was like oh man
but seriously though what is
and so you do kind of lose your mind in
grief
because as a child of divorce
the show was a family
and i couldn't really tolerate the
randomness
of the disillusion of the family
and i felt like we hadn't reached our
potential creatively that we were just
getting going
and obviously a lot of the movies was an
attempt we're an attempt to try to tap
into
all that was happening creatively with
all those different people right on the
show
you know when you're doing uh when
you're directing i always wondered about
this are you the kind of director that
you get it as written
say it as and then you kind of let
people improvise
do you shout things out what's your
process on set like that
yeah i think that's about it i try to
write it as well as i can or have them
write it as well as they can kelly
clarkson did you hear that
like that was seth and evan making a
list of curses
so
[Music]
we know we're gonna whack steve
we have five cameras on it we know we
can do it once
we've explained to romney and seth
and paul rudd the basic vibe of their
reactions to it although they did react
differently than we had planned
and
the whole thing was like a start and
stop
uh
improvisation
but one of the key aspects was
that steve would yell at the waxer when
i was a kid i went to action park
in new york did you see the documentary
yeah incredible and so those cars that
would like ride these alpine slide cars
everyone would always wipe out they
would skin they would skin their elbows
like all that you know they would like
fall out of the cart and be on this like
cement track people died
well i think in other rides do they die
doing that i don't know if they read
that but we would all get really badly
injured and go to the nurse and when we
got to the nurse she would put a
disinfectant on where the skin had been
ripped off and every person in new
jersey
would have the same reaction they would
spray the disinfectant and then the
person be like you [ __ ]
you know at the nurse the poor sweet
lady and every person would walk up like
they weren't gonna do it and then they
would do it and so that was what was in
my head right that he would explode at
her in a way you wouldn't see coming
and so i said to seth and evan
just make a list of interesting
curses
and then i said make one column of clean
ones so we have alternatives in case we
need to show this on abc one day we can
re-edit a clean version and so then seth
walked up to me and there's a video of
this
uh on youtube there's the making of the
waxing scene right and one of the things
just said kelly clarkson
but yeah it's very open space we want to
get a good version of the scene we want
to throw lines at people we want them to
improvise
you know we're really open to anything
happening and you know sometimes the
best joke in the scene
is the the random thing that's just on a
list that seth and evan hand you right
do you ever get things that you just are
like this this like this isn't working
it's just not working i mean it's fine
it's fine i gotta let it go i gotta move
it on we've worked on the scene we've
been improvising it's not funny
there are definitely scenes where you
think i guess that's not one for the
history books
and then you hope when you get into post
that you can fix it and then every once
in a while you just have to put a joke
in the back of someone's head an adr
where you just record a new joke right
you show the other actor and
and and we have saved a thousand
post-production jobs and i remember
wes
and owen talking about james brooks
forcing them to do that in bottle rocket
and if you watch bottle rocket there's
an incredible joke incredible on the
back of people's heads yeah
but
you know a lot of that process i learned
from ben stiller when we did the ben
stiller show
because he would do this agent character
and he would interview people like
roseanne and tom or run dmc and it was
him giving terrible advice it was all
kind of insulting right
and what he would always do is tell them
we were done shooting this the sketch
and then after they left he would shoot
his single again and just say much
meaner things
the things he was afraid to say to their
face oh my god and then we would just
riff all these crazy runs
when they weren't there right
do you laugh a lot are you constantly
laughing are you sewing your head
because you want it to be great you want
to be great that you don't you're not
feeling the funny as much as everyone
else is it depends certain things you
are like
that's funny okay that'll work let's
move on uh and then other times you just
start giggling i just made this movie
called the bubble the bubble which where
does it come out that's going to come
out in the later in the spring
and crazy this movie is insane folks
yeah i laughed so hard there's so many
it's so ridiculous and it's like right
at the beginning of the pandemic and all
these actors are at this hotel yeah and
they're just all going crazy yeah it's
like actors trying to make a dinosaur
action movie in london during the early
part of the pandemic having nervous
breakdowns
and
fred armisen plays the director so he's
supposed to be the sundance winner who
gets his first big budget movie and he
doesn't know how to handle it and it's
during the pandemic
and fred would make me laugh
out loud so there's some people that
just make you laugh yeah maria bamford
plays
uh
that there's a tick tock star who's been
jammed into the movie played by my
daughter iris and we we did zooms with
maria bamford as her mother so she's
zooming conversations with her mother
and maria just gets me
every every time she's like is timothy
oily fans in the movie i loved timothy
[Laughter]
uh seth rogen uh is it true that you
credit him with influencing you to make
your work more outrageously dirty well
certainly seth felt like
comedy wasn't
edgy enough for his taste right so when
we first started
working together
uh you know in movies after undeclared
where we couldn't be that edgy we were
you know desperately trying to get
someone to pay attention to super bad
and not having a lot of success
one of the stories
that always makes uh seth and i laugh is
that
there was this producer that we added to
our team because we thought maybe it's
us maybe if we had a more powerful
producer he could get us the money so we
we have this producer join our team and
then suddenly he gets hired to be the
head of paramount
and we think well now we'll make the
movie he's the head of paramount and the
first thing he did his head of paramount
was to say no to the movie that he was
the producer
um
but
during the the writing of the
40-year-old virgin
you know seth was one of the producers
on it and
he really thought it was funny to make
steve uncomfortable
so in his work
as the guy in the stockroom with steve
he went hard and dirty and uncomfortable
and it made us laugh
so hard to do that to steve and steve i
think as a comedy person also isn't like
a dirty
comedian right you don't think anything
like that you know he's a smart subtle
witty brilliant guy and he'll go there
but it really made steve uncomfortable
and to the point where steve wasn't sure
where the line should be
in the movie and i think seth was a big
you know a big influence on
a lot of you know that kind of
you know talking about a donkey show in
mexico type
type joke runs right you know and that
extended through you know
other things like you know super bad and
pineapple express i mean he really wants
to put the pedal to the metal and some
of the joke style you take a lot of
risks with with newcomers i see
newcomers like pete davidson and uh amy
schumer who had a ton of they didn't
have a ton of acting experience and so
when you take on a role like that like
this is the leader all we're doing king
of staten island
how much work is that extra on you to
get performances out of someone to i
mean
that's that seems like it's a difficult
task you're setting yourself up for
someone who hasn't really acted or maybe
they just naturally fall into place it's
not really about the performances as
much as the writing
the writing just takes
a lot of work
and it just takes why is that what do
you what do you mean because
you know when the movies work they're
usually very personal even if they're
big comedies the core idea of it is a
personal idea to amy or two-pete about
relationships or about getting over
trauma and grief
and so you're asking someone to really
go there
these aren't like ghostbusters type
premises yeah they're very personal
and so you have to
develop with them
over sometimes an extended period of
time with amy was
it was kind of short because she wrote
if you gave her notes
she would hang you a new draft like five
days later
she really worked hard
and
and when we get to the set usually we've
done auditions and we've done table
reads and by the time we get there we
know
what we're doing the the hard work is in
the conception of it i think bill burr
is just genius in that movie too train
all right and um
he's such a good actor he's such a
i love that guy yeah he was in an
episode of crashing
with pete holmes
and we were all blown away by his acting
i know and i just thought oh my god
there's so much more here with bill and
he's not in a lot of movies where he's
you know featured and given
the space
to create from his place right and very
early on pete was like you got to get
bill burr you got to get bilber and
we were so lucky and then he was even 10
times better
than we thought he might be but again
like the core of that is very personal
bill and pete know each other there's an
intimacy there
bill cares about pete and even though in
the movie he's annoyed by pete you kind
of feel underneath that there's some
love there right and so they have that
chemistry that comes from life
that we're able to tap into in the movie
this is these are from my patrons i have
a patreon account these are rapid fire
got you this you just answer them as
quickly as you you would like to or i'll
babble for 11 minutes i need you you can
do whatever the hell you want i know
you're a busy guy so i don't want to
keep you too much i just love this i
seldom am really just like excited about
something i could talk to you for hours
and i'm not going to do that to you
because i know you're busy so here we go
[ __ ] talking with judd apatow
nika what does your style of feedback to
an actor sound like
usually i'm walking up and i'm nervous
so i have to hide the fact that i'm
nervous about doing my job well so it's
usually enthusiasm
coming through my stress about if i'm
gonna screw up the scene so it might be
like uh
yeah i think that's that's working maybe
there's a thing that we could do where
you that's problem that's probably the
vice
yeah i'm not like i'm just kind of i
probably sound
stressed
so people are a little insecure like is
judd happy well no more like i'm
praising but also letting you know we're
going to do
a whole bunch of other things but the
key thing i do as a director is i let
people know we're going to take our time
i think most people's acting diminishes
because they don't know how many takes
they're going to get right and so you're
like god i better nail it maybe i'm
gonna get two shots at this i always
tell the actors we're gonna be here
until we like it and tell me if you like
it do you like what you did because uh
i'm feeling good now and i feel like
just saying that to people
they get way better and all that stress
that screws up their performance
disappears if they know that you're
going to give them
time and that you're going to pay
attention to if they're happy with it do
you get actors that are just like i
don't want any more takes do we got it
come on what else you want i'm just
ready to move on i'm tired i don't want
to uh not too often but
i remember
with fred armisten
he would just make me laugh so i would
make him riff for like 10 straight
minutes sometimes and he never would
give you a look like
okay judd we got it
never really the first second looks
exactly the same as 10 minutes in like
if i didn't say cut and and you had a
digital card a digital memory card that
lasted an hour he would never stop and
it would all be at the same level
were you ever nervous about giving an
actor uh direction that was just kind of
like oh he's gonna snap at me or so some
guy who just like isn't that fun to work
with you don't have to say any names
well riptorn was terrified because
anything you said to him he was going to
knee-jerk know you right so if you said
uh
uh rip i think that you might be a
little more irritated here i'm not
irritated
i know what's going on here i don't need
to be irritated
and then what he would do is
you know blow up at you and then if you
did like three more takes on the third
one he would suddenly take your note
without talking about it
and so that i realized was the trick he
never wanted to say you were right but
then he would try it leanne what
surprised you the most about being a
parent
or what surprises you about being a
parent i you know everything surprised
me because
as you know from knocked up we didn't
know we were gonna become parents and so
every what surprised me was that every
single thing i knew about being a parent
was from what i had seen in tv shows and
in movies and everything that was
difficult about being a parent wasn't in
tvs and tv and movies
like none of it applied
that's that was the thing that surprised
me right does iris and mod do you are
you happy they're in going into acting
they're interacting they're obviously
doing a lot of stuff mods on euphoria
right are you excited about this you
like that she's kind of following your
footsteps she's doing this i mean
obviously you're not an actor but
are you happy about that
it's hard for me to judge it because
as a kid i so wanted to do this type of
work
so there's no part of me that thinks
this is a mistake for them to have the
same fun i'm having right but yet it's
very stressful
and you want them to be in it for the
right reasons and you want them to be
passionate about
you know their artistic life you don't
want them in it for the ego right you
want that's tough that's tough yeah and
so we've talked about that from birth
you know like why are you doing it you
know because if it's just to get liked
by people it won't work yeah it has to
be because you care about what you're
doing and i think you know they're both
making choices
that are about quality and following
their passion so euphoria has been
pretty
incredible this year and it's been fun
to see mod on the show and iris is
really funny
in the bubble yeah and yeah we had a
good time shooting that so do they like
your direction do they go dad
i don't know when iris was on love the
tv show we did for netflix thank you i i
when i would show up on the set when i
wasn't directing like john slattery
directed a bunch of the episodes
iris would always say why are you here
i'm like i'm the producer of the show i
don't need you here
like she so enjoyed not being directed
by me
maya p which year films would you love
to make a sequel to
out of all the out of all the movies i'm
pretty close to
deciding if i'm going to make this is 50
in the next year
i have an idea for it i'm trying to
decide if people really want it
uh
but i do want it i'll be 50 in four
months yeah i get a lot of feedback on
this as 40 i feel like
the world of tick tock and instagram
has elevated it there's so many little
moments that circulate
and i get a lot of people saying are you
gonna do this is 50 it's time like
they've tracked it that it's been 10
years
so
probably
probably that one and i always wanted
them to do a sequel to super bad and i
know that jonah said oh it'll be funny
to do it when we're 70 or 80.
but i really wanted them to do a
superbad in college where
jonah flunks out of college and just
shows up and visits michael sarah at
college but everyone everyone was like
nah we don't want to screw up super bad
by accidentally making a crappy second
one and i would always say the same
thing well that's like saying don't make
the second episode of the of the
sopranos
like so why do you think we would screw
up the second one yeah
uh danny i'd like to go back to the
start of judd's career and ask the
favorite joke you wrote for larry
sanders the show was groundbreaking
like a favorite joke i wrote for larry
sanders couldn't be a joke or a moment
or a scene or you know one thing i'm
very proud of that i worked on
at larry sanders was
the jim carrey moment in the finale
so jim carrey said he would do the show
after
not really answering for six years so
for six years i asked him to do the show
and he would always
not say no but not say yes
and then finally i called him i said jim
it's literally the last episode this is
your only shot to be on the larry
sanders show and he said i'll do it if i
could be the best person who's ever done
it it has to be the best scene
in the history of this show that's what
he said to you he said to me i said okay
jim let's do it and so
we were trying to figure out what it
would be and there was a very funny idea
about
the gym would come on and then in the
commercial break
he would be really mean to larry and say
oh you're leaving
you're leaving tv you think you're gonna
do movies i'll destroy you
and so we had that idea but we didn't
know what else to do and
years before
when both of us were single one night we
were talking to these these women at the
improv and
they live like across the street we wind
up across the street
and like nothing like
happened but they made us pancakes in
the middle of the night
and then a woman put on jennifer
holliday in
uh
uh what's that movie not um dream girls
dream girl doing it and i'm telling you
yeah that big song and she just
lip-synced it for us and it was like a
blue velvet kind of bizarre moment with
me and jim in these strangers apartment
watching
this woman lip sync
very emotionally to this song and i
never forgot it and i said to jim maybe
you could sing that song
on the last larry sanders
and
he did it it was so incredible and after
the first take gary was like yeah that's
it we're done and jim's like no i want
to do it again i could do it better
and
gary was like you want to do it again
like he couldn't believe that there was
any energy in jim's body
to like try to do it and it was better
and it was better it was and here's the
crazy thing i'm i'm
editing the documentary about gary
shandling and i get the footage the raw
dailies
because i'm going to like re-cut the
sequence in the dock what's in the dock
is not how it aired
and i noticed my mom is in the audience
and
and also
the guy who owns largo my good friend
mark flanagan is in the audience with
john bryan
wow who scored eternal sunshine and the
spotless mind and a lot of my moves
and that
that really blew me away so in the dark
i i use the moment where you see my mom
that's beautiful did you get emotional
oh yeah i just couldn't believe it it
was weird do you get emotional a lot oh
yeah i'm an easy easy crowd what makes
you cry
uh everything everything i could cry
literally the amount of times i'm crying
it's it's like when you see your
daughter have a good performance or
something oh yeah oh yeah literally
everything i mean uh i mean i like being
emotionally accessible and
and vulnerable so yeah tv movies
you know most things
yeah i'll i'll go
really hard i think about when i was a
kid my grandfather died of a heart
attack when i was a senior in high
school
and i'm at his funeral
and he had produced
a record by red buttons the borscht belt
comedian and i'm sitting in a chair
balling my eyes out just snot and just
crying
and then suddenly like someone said judd
this is red buttons and i like shook his
hand they're emotional man
mid snotty
ball and cry
oh man that's amazing what you still go
to therapy you do therapy oh yeah you go
you get anxiety you deal with all that
[ __ ] yeah
a lot of times i have two therapists
really i have
all the last few years i've had two
therapists
with two different ideas one's
a little more
of a more buddhist mindfulness
going into this very shambling path
maybe and the other one's a little more
about
like
evolution and fight-or-flight response
and just almost the brain chemistry that
leads to your
panic or anxiety or depression and i
found that all really interesting just
the way evolution has built you to be
depressed it built you to be scared it
thinks it's saving your life
my therapist said to me
there's nothing your brain would like to
do more than get you to stay in bed all
day because then you're safe yeah then a
bear won't eat you yeah and
and just the reality of what you're
working
against that your body holds on to the
bad stuff and kind of doesn't hold on to
the good stuff because remembering the
bad stuff and evolution saved your life
oh don't go in that cave that's the one
with the bear and so you'd remember it
the rest of your life but if you had a
nice
meal and ate some berries in the woods
you would just forget it five minutes
later and that's really what
life is that you tend to hold on to
the dark stuff yeah and so yeah and
lately lately i haven't i haven't gotten
a little while
because i i there's a couple of
self-help books i like so much i'm
trying to see if i could really tune
into them there's one called the
untethered soul
by michael singer
that is it's all about the things we do
to try to make everything in life work
and how it makes no sense that you want
every interaction to be positive and
everything to work out well and how
we're just making ourselves crazy
mentally by that process we're trying
too hard maybe
you know how i look at it i i think of
it this way i think i'm in comedy but my
big issue
is that i need to lighten up
oh that's the perfect guy andy look you
got the george carlin documentary what's
it called we have a title yet it's
called george carlin's american dream
george collins you must have just come
up with that recently well that was yeah
and that's the name of the big routine
that some of the documentary is
built around and then uh sicker in the
head you could you could order online
now the book of interviews and the
bubble will be out this spring on
netflix there'll be a trailer
coming out in a couple of weeks and
you'll see
something super weird
super weird super weird we went somebody
called me up and they i let them see it
and they went it's bonkers
you just it is it's more bonkers than
anything you've ever done i think yeah
it's a it's as close as we get to
it's not exactly this but it is a kind
of a combo between tropic thunder a
christopher guest movie and and a mel
brooks movie sure i could see that it's
meant to just be
a way of saying to the audience
the last few years have been so terrible
can we at least laugh at it yeah can we
just take a moment to commiserate about
what we've been through look at the [ __ ]
we've been through this is kind of like
a little piece of candy about this has
been an absolute joy uh i can't thank
you enough for being here ryan's a big
fan of yours as are
everyone i think everyone out there is
probably a fan of judd apatos i
appreciate it safe to say that uh i hope
you have more and more success and bring
us more and more
good feeling movies and i hope uh
50 year old virgin not 50 year old
virgin that could be it it could maybe
do a combo crossover
crossover that would be amazing uh thank
you for allowing me to be inside of you
today
i've always wanted it this is really i
mean i reached out for it
you did and not only that but you know
it sounds like guided you into me i i
just sent a message to him this never
happens by the way i just said i'd love
to have you on my podcast and usually
it's like oh whatever whatever he
immediately responds and goes let's do
it
i'm a listener
i like it i was on the i was on a plane
i was listening to the kevin nealon
interview
and you were talking about midnight in
the garden of good evil
and i literally looked up and someone
was watching it in front of me and you
were on the screen what is that i took a
picture of it
and sent it to me
what are the odds of that it was really
yeah
and kevin neeland was amazing about i
love kevin neal and he was like rose mom
is this therapy for you this is he's
just leaning back oh my god he's so
funny i love him uh thank you this is
amazing thank you all right
oh what would you like mostly about that
one
just did that it happened
you were you know i know what's funny is
that you never
ever have asked this but well i'm
walking out with judd before he didn't
see it but he goes hey you go hey can
you get a picture with me well no what
happened what happened i think you
sensed
i i did i didn't ask i sensed it in your
face you're like oh you just went ahead
and said here's here's how you did it
and it was really kind of nice it was
very subconscious uh you went hey let's
all get a picture and then you're like
oh i can't get myself in the frame here
i'll just do one of you two and then you
did one
bam i remember that now you do well i
didn't ask we did it i'm not good about
asking for things and you did it for me
well nice i appreciate it i appreciate
you appreciating it yeah and uh i think
he appreciated it he's uh
he's a gem man he's a legend he's uh
judd if you're listening thank you thank
you for coming on the podcast i hope you
enjoyed it as much as we did
um and uh just a reminder guys if you
like the podcast please write a review
please write a review and follow us at
insideepodcast on instagram and facebook
at insideyoupod on the twitter i'm going
to be in st louis this coming weekend to
sign autographs and to do a smallville
nights improv show with tom welling get
your tickets i'll be in liverpool the
weekend of may 21st uh june 10th i'll be
in metropolis illinois uh australia june
17th through the 28th
and uh also uh my band sunspin we're
coming out with a new album we're going
to be playing uh may 28th which is a
saturday am i correct is that a saturday
how would you know that uh the it is a
saturday you're sure i am
because i'm on a plane on the tour it is
this is a sunday it's a saturday folks
um so
thank you for all the support and love
but come come watch the band you can go
to stageit.com get tickets or you can go
to sunspin.com you could also book zooms
you can go on cameo with me i'm on there
and uh what would i do without my
patrons my lovable patrons who support
the podcast i talk about you every week
because it's just the truth and you
stick around and
it's it's marvelous sometimes i feel
like do i want to still do this podcast
and then you know so much feedback so
much love that how could i not want to
do it so uh thank you for keeping me
motivated excited
and feeling blessed
uh go to patreon.com inside of you if
you want to join patreon and help the
podcast out uh right now oh so big
thanks to ryan right here my man bryce
my man jason couldn't do the podcast
without you
literally couldn't do it i just i'd be
[ __ ] i'd be completely [ __ ]
did i say f twice in a row you try not
to say it
it's you know it's okay every once in a
while it's all right you're an adult i'm
an adult here we go these are the top
tier patrons if you join patreon if
you're in the top tier you get your name
read off every week on every episode
these are the people that really help
out nancy d leah s sean uh sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h nico p
robert b
jason w kristen k raj c joshua d cjp
jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly e mike e eldon
uh supremo 99 more ramira ramirez
santiago m chad w liam p janine r maya p
maddie s belinda and chris h dave h
sheila g brad d ray h tabitha t wow tom
n liliana a italia m betsy d
uh chad l rochelle marion med k dan k
dan n
as in nice
angel m rhiannon c cory k super sam dev
nixon michelle a jeremy c andy t cody r
gavinato david c john b brandy d uh vore
camille
uh n
h s s the
c joey m willie f david h omar i design
otg eugene and leah chris p nikki g
corey nicole patricia heather l jake b
james b bobbitt joshua b tony g and
don't forget
mel s can't forget mel s
uh orlando c john b caroline r rob e rob
robbie i said paul c christine s sarah s
eric h spring
jennifer r shane r
and emma are
those are the top tier patrons can do it
without you i thank you guys all for
listening i really appreciate you we're
going to keep doing this try to give you
interviews that make you think that help
you out maybe that uh some people you
can relate to
um we try to get deep every episode but
uh from myself michael rosemond here in
the hollywood hills of california
ryan taylor's here as well
an old wave to old camera c that's
camera c we're going to call that camera
cena we're going to call that camera c
after all these years great uh we love
you be good to yourself most importantly
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you it means
the world and i'm wearing the hat today
i haven't worn the hat in a while i
don't feel like i wear the hat as
frequently it's a good hat it's a good
hat on me and i can't find one that's
just like this it's got to be a big
enough hat to fit my head i've got a big
head ryan he's got a sasquatch head i
got a sasquatch hat and head so you said
a head hat head head whatever
i love you guys thanks so much
[Music]